Mika's blouse is cute. Thank you. It's a
regular au. They sell those too.
I'm also a fan of lace, but Yuzuki, you
can wear whatever you want. People say it's
different from their image.
Oh, I saw it on Pinsta, and the
color isn't too sweet, and I think it's
cute, and it's fashionable. I
wanted to try it on. I wish it was open, but no, beige
doesn't suit me at all.
Mika-chan,
Brevet dummy,
don't put that out in the world.  I
learned it from Dana-chan, and I
also know how to look at it, which is a fashionable word.
Brevet is a blue base with bluish skin, and
colors such as pink and purple
look good on it. House is a yellow base, and you bought it with
skin such as orange or beige.  It looks good on me. It's a
word used as a reference when choosing makeup and clothes. I'm like, I'm going to stop saying this.